until the last moment the U.N Secretary
General had been trying to persuade
Russia to stay in the deal but President
Putin didn't even bother to reply to his
latest letter as he addressed reporters
his mood was Grim I deeply regret the
decision by the Russian Federation to
terminate the implementation of the
Black Sea initiative
including the withdrawal of Russian
security guarantees for navigation in
the Northwestern part of the Black Sea
these initiatives has ensured the safe
passage of over 32 million metric tones
of food commodities from Ukrainian ports
inside the security Council western
countries were United in their
condemnation of Russia let us be clear
Russia's actions are taking food out of
the mouths of the poorest people across
Africa the Middle East
and Latin America and now with
announcement that it will withdraw from
the Black Sea grain initiative Moscow is
threatening even more people more
children with starvation
Russia decided not to attend the meeting
at foreign minister level instead
sending its Deputy Ambassador he said
the deal was terminated but added this
the Russian Federation will stand ready
to consider its resumption only when
concrete results are achieved rather
than promises and assurances from
Western capitals Ukraine's foreign
minister dimitro kaleba told me there
are different views here at the UN about
whether the deal is completely dead
there are two schools of thought now
I can conclude that from the
conversation I've had I have had some
are
far less optimistic and others are
slightly more optimistic I'm told that
during his meeting with the UN Secretary
General Mr kaleba raised a suggestion by
his boss president zielinski that
perhaps the deal could continue operated
by Ukraine Tokyo and the UN without the
participation of Russia senior U.N
officials though are very doubtful about
that they say that no ship company or
insurance company would want to risk
their vessel coming under Russian attack
James Bay's Al Jazeera at the United
Nations